[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody that was really
phenomenal to see I am Bryan Keating a
professor Chancellor's professor of
physics at the University of California
San Diego that's a real treat and honor
for me to be able to welcome everybody
here in person and soon to be joined by
our famous astronaut hero in space
Jessica Muir so it's great pleasure to
have not only with us
the distinguished scientist that we have
in Jessica or herself of course but also
the Fulton K through eight middle school
as well as the memorial preparatory
school for scholars and athletes so it's
really fantastic there's gonna be QA
from these middle school students and
there's also going to be some questions
from online viewers at the that we've
solicited as well as well as from
graduate students from the Scripps
Institution of Oceanography so it's
going to be a fantastic program my
specialization is studying space in
particular studying the Big Bang the
origin of the universe is studying the
the far distant reaches of our universe
so it's a great treat for me to be
actually communicating for the first
time doing this sort of long-distance
phone call and it's going to be a real
treat for you as well I'm sure so just a
couple minutes we'll be connecting with
dr. jessica muir who as you saw has an
impressive resume that's taken her from
here in la jolla where we are today
all the way into space and down to
Antarctica and almost everywhere in
between just a remarkable career in
Antarctica you heard that she studied
the physiology of emperor penguins which
are everybody's favorite bird and
there's any many movies written made
about them happy feet in particular one
of my kids favorite movies and of course
I've been to an article twice and I'm
just as fascinated and a little bit
jealous of Jessica as well for all the
trip she's gotten to take she actually
we learned earlier today in the Q&A
session with the middle school students
alone about her passion how it was
ignited when she was a student herself
in high school and how she wrote in a
diary that she hopes someday to explore
outer space herself so she's really
proof that these dreams that you have
can come true especially for
those of you and many of you here today
are interested in careers that are in
the so called stem field science
technology engineering and mathematics
and of course we're known for many
things at UCSD including those fields
and especially here at Scripps
Institution of Oceanography she made
history in October everybody remembers
when Jessica and her fellow astronaut
Christina made a first all-female
spacewalk in the history of space
exploration just a phenomenal experience
and for us to be proud of she joins a
long list of women astronauts in
particular have been associated with UC
San Diego Kate Rubin's Sally Ride and
Megan McArthur and of course the first
American woman in space Katherine
Sullivan received an honour spoke at a
commencement here at Scripps Institution
of Oceanography in the 1980s and that's
another connection that UCSD and Scripps
Institution of Oceanography in
particular has with the exploration not
just of our planet but of our solar
system and indeed the universe itself so
when she's in space currently she's
traveling about five miles every second
she gets to witness sunrise and sunset
sixteen times a day but I bet it never
gets old for her and she's she's
traveling you know many many thousands
of miles an hour to only takes 90
minutes for her if you worked out the
math traveling five miles per second to
to cover the entire distance the
circumference of Earth from where she is
in low-earth orbit so we're gonna get
ready to connect to to the space station
and have a conversation with our
wonderful alumni Jessica Muir dr.
Jessica Muir I'd like to now welcome the
director of Scripps Institution of
Oceanography dr. Margaret linen to say
some words about the institution and
about today's event so thank you very
much
[Applause]
thanks Brian and before we connect to
Jessica I just want to join Brian in
welcoming all of you from Fulton and
from Memorial preparatory we are really
pleased to share this day with you I
hope you're as excited as I am and all
of us at Scripps art science can really
take you to some amazing places and in
the little film we saw of Jessica under
the ice and Antarctica and slithering
through narrow places into caves those
are great examples but look where she is
now she's going to be speaking to us
from space and we hope that that you're
as excited about science being able to
take you these kinds of places as we are
so Jessica welcome back to Scripps
Margaret line in here as well as a
hundred and fifty middle school students
from Fulton k-8 and Memorial preparatory
and of course a lot of your friends and
supporters from here at Scripps and the
UC San Diego community and as director I
want to make sure you know how proud we
are of everything that you've done with
this extraordinary background in
oceanography and being able to realize
this dream of yours to go to space and
we know that you're doing a lot of
science up there and thank you so much
for taking time out of busy schedule to
talk with us back here in San Diego
thank you so much Brian and Margaret it
and hello to all of the Fulton and
memorial students and all of my
colleagues and friends back at Scripps
it really means so much for me to be
able to share my life up here with all
of you it really is one of the big
objectives of my mission is to share
this experience with as many people as I
can because I am so incredibly fortunate
to be up here I don't want to take any
time away from the great students of the
questions have to ask so I think we
should just get right into those great
to Jessica and Brian is going to lead us
in taking care of the questions Brian
Thank You Margot thank you so much
Jessica it's such a treat to have you up
there looking down on us and talking to
us so we have questions from students
and they're gonna line up now so if you
submitted a question please line up and
we have a procedure for you to go up
there it's the most expensive phone call
we've ever made at Scripps Institution
of our so let's take advantage of it
let's be efficient so first up I believe
is melody and she is from Fulton K
through 8 so melody please take it away
my name is melody Wheatley I'm an eighth
grader from Fulton k3 and my question is
who was your inspiration to become an
astronaut Thank You melody actually
there is no one individual person that I
can identify I started saying that I
wanted to be an astronaut when I was
five years old and I think I was always
enthralled with exploration and nature
in general probably it was my mother
that inspired me with that I think I
also saw on news and and on TV the space
shuttle program we had a very active
space shuttle program at the time in the
80s when I was growing up and something
must have captivated my attention and my
excitement with that and really just
planted that seed for me to want to
explore explore the world around me and
to explore even beyond that here in
space my name is Andres Cardona and were
you afraid of the takeoff I wasn't
afraid actually and I think one of the
reasons why we don't really have that
fear response or at least I didn't is
because we received so much incredible
training at NASA I have been training
for my mission up here for essentially
six years so we have been over and over
all of the different things that we'll
be experiencing in the last two years I
spent a lot of time in Russia training
with the Russians and the the Russian
space program since we launched launched
a space on the Soyuz rocket we spent a
lot of time in simulators preparing for
every
step in every face of the mission so it
was really interesting I had been
through that so many times in a
simulator which looked exactly like the
real thing that sometimes during the
actual liftoff I had to remind myself
that this was finally real you get so
immersed in what you're doing and so
focused with all the steps and actions
you have to take as an operator that
sometimes you forget that it's not just
the same as all the practice that you've
been doing there were a few not so
subtle reminders though when the rocket
started groaning and shifting a little
bit and then as this different stages of
the rocket separated and we've got
higher and higher away from the earth
you could actually see those things
falling off of the rocket outside of the
window so once I started seeing those
signs I realized it was true but it
really wasn't any sort of fear it was
really just an excitement and a little
bit of disbelief and incredulity that my
dream was actually finally coming true
why this is an International Space
Station you need different kinds of
scientists like biologists and
geologists well I think there are two
main reasons why we want to have
scientists like biologists and
geologists and all other types up here
first of all it's the best way to have
any efficient and high functioning and
successful team is to have a
well-rounded team you can imagine if you
had six people up here that all had
exactly the same background they might
not be that creative and problem solving
so if we have maybe one biologist one
physicist one military pilot one doctor
one electrical engineer we're
representing all different kinds of
fields that we can become vital to
accomplishing the mission that we have
to dealing with the experiments that
we're conducting up here and really most
importantly we are all critical thinkers
and problem solvers just like any good
scientist no matter what field you're in
and I think those are some of the most
important attributes for our work up
here
[Music]
well Brian mentioned the common theme in
everything that we do up here and that
is the stem field so science technology
engineering and math now the nice thing
is there are a lot of different options
within those fields all of those fields
could lead to a career like this one to
become an astronaut you do have to have
a degree in one of those areas but the
choices are really broad for example I'm
a life scientist a biologist and a
physiologist as I think you already just
saw up here with me on my crew there's
an electrical engineer there's a
military doctor there's a military test
pilot with a background in engineering
and then our two Russian cosmonauts up
here as well with their engineering and
military and backgrounds so all of these
different backgrounds are our basic
paths that you can use to get up here so
spending time in any of those science
technology engineering and math courses
really helped us all get where we are
today hi my name is Naomi nice open
floor 10k and my question is what ever
research they do on the space station
and do you have due any experience
outside the space station
well it's really amazing how many
different types of experiments we
conduct up here and as a scientist it is
so exciting because as you can imagine
once you eliminate these gravity-driven
effects that are always present no
matter where you are on the earth you
might unveil a whole variety of
responses and results that we never even
thought possible so we do experiments
ranging from physiology and medicine how
the spaceflight environment affects our
human bodies we do experiments about
combustion even flames burn differently
in space without gravity without
convection driving that motion flames
burn differently so we study in a
community in a chamber we study how
these how different things burn in terms
of flammability and safety responses
also in terms of fuel efficiency that
might enhance fuel efficiency on earth
and also for future spacecraft we do
biotechnology experiments I did a genome
sequencing a DNA sequencing experiment
called genes in space up here and we do
fluids experiments we do really as I
mentioned any type of experiment and it
is really an amazing playground as a
scientist to be up here and outside the
space station I was fortunate enough to
go outside of the space station three
times now on spacewalks and those are
actually not for scientific experiments
those are for repair jobs we have
Hardware both inside and outside the
space station that's critical to making
sure that all the systems work up here
to accomplish our mission and one of the
things that needed to be upgraded where
our batteries if you've seen a picture
of the space station you can see the
immense very impressive solar arrays we
harness all of the energy that we use up
here all of the power requirements come
from the Sun from solar energy but of
course since we have these multiple
times when we are in Sun and then in
shade throughout the day we also have to
have some efficient batteries to keep
that energy when we're not in direct
sunlight so we conducted a series of
spacewalks to upgrade those batteries to
better more efficient batteries lithium
ion battery it's just like you're using
down on earth as well and that I think
was one of the most amazing
things that I've done while I'm up here
is venturing out of the hatch in a
spacesuit and having really nothing
between you and the earth below except
for you at the visor of your helmet it
really is an extraordinary experience my
name is Bryan Keating I'm in 42nd grade
UC San Diego and I have a question from
Instagram follower one of your millions
of Instagram followers and I remind
folks you can follow Jessica on
instagram and twitter at astro Jessa
underscore Jessica this is actually a
question from one of the scripts in
Instagram followers and her name is Alma
venero and she would like to know
besides coming to UCSD what's the best
advice for young women who want to
become astronauts there does seem to be
a trend with female astronauts and UCSD
it's a great connection but I think the
most important thing to do is to make
sure that you identify your passion and
do what it is that you really care about
once you've done that you do need to
work really hard to make those dreams
come true and it sounds a bit trite when
I say it but it really is true I think
this is proof that your dreams can come
true I've been saying I wanted to be an
astronaut since I was five years old and
because I had identified that as my
passion and also identified other
aspects of science and exploration that
led me down that road and pursued it
with a lot of hard work and dedication
and perseverance and then a lot of luck
all wrapped together to actually get me
where I am today and the point is really
anybody can do it if that's what you set
your mind out to and just to follow up
on that previous question I think I
misunderstood a little bit there are
other experiments outside the space
station there are other instruments like
the Alpha Magnetic Spectrometer
that are measuring high-energy radiation
so looking at things like understanding
and unravelling more about the origins
of the universe and this is actually an
instrument which we just finished
repairing with a series of spacewalks so
it's all connected up here thank you
next up we have a question from well
obstacles did you face and ordered so I
shouldn't be able to
scientists and sorry could you repeat
that one one more time what obstacles
did you face in order to actually be an
scientist okay
obstacles well I think a lot of hard
work a lot of application processes but
just like anything in life things that
are worth it things that give you a
great reward involve a lot of hard work
involve some of those obstacles and
involve failing along the way for me one
of my big failures along the way was
actually in applying for this job it
took me a few different times to apply
before I was accepted and four years
before I started in 2013 I also
interviewed for this job in 2009 I made
it all the way to the final round of
astronaut applicants and the people at
Scripps that are there with you today
remember that well because it was just
at the time where I was finishing my PhD
at Scripps and things went well at the
interview I knew I'd given it my best
shot but only nine people were selected
and I wasn't one of them so that was a
pretty big obstacle to overcome because
I had gone through everything and I
thought well you know I'd failed at it
it didn't happen it didn't work out that
time and so I could have given up then
but I didn't I waited until the next
time that I could apply and when I
applied again this time even though I
thought well it'll be worth applying
just to see but I'm sure it'll be the
same result and I'm gonna go through all
of this again and psychologically and
mentally it's probably going to be quite
difficult but if I don't apply if I give
up now that I'll never know and sure
enough this time it worked out and this
time brought me to where I am today so I
think that's just it was a lesson
learned for me no matter how many
obstacles to end in your way you have to
be ready to persevere and to keep on
trying even if you fail along the way
hello my name is Johanna and was your
space training difficult to master and
if so what part of your training was
both complex to adapt you there are a
lot of aspects of our training that are
difficult in summer you know it depends
on the individual about which things are
more difficult we do flight training we
learn the Russian language since
everybody up here and the space station
speaks both English and Russian we learn
all about the different types of systems
onboard the international space station
since we have to be the people not just
living up here we also if we if the
toilet breaks or a light bulb needs to
be changed we have to be able to fix
that toilet and change the light bulb we
can't just call a plumber or an
electrician but I think the one thing
that is most challenging for most people
is learning how to use and operate the
spacesuit when you're in the spacesuit
you weigh over 400 pounds and it's very
cumbersome it's pressurized you're kind
of out at these weird angles so you have
really minimal dexterity in these big
pressurized gloves and it's also very
mentally challenging because your task
has to be so focused and it's a lot of
hard work physically it's about the
equivalent of running a marathon
so with that physical and mental
challenge it's certainly one of the more
difficult things that we do but I think
it's the most rewarding thing that we do
and as I just described being outside in
a spacesuit was I think to me the
highlight of my mission thus far hi my
name is Alexei Navarre and my question
is what are some hardships that you have
gone through that helped you get to
where you are today
well I think the biggest hardship was
the one that I just mentioned about
going through the application process
and having failed at it
deciding that I wanted to put myself
through that again so just remembering
that it is always worth it to take a
risk in that if you don't take that risk
then you probably won't end up with a
reward in the end next we have a
question from one of our graduate
students a fellow graduate student yeah
and her name is Tasha Anna Osbourne hi
dr. Mir it's really nice to meet you
virtually my question is what can we
learn about Earth's changing climate by
observing earth from space and by
observing other planets that is a great
question and that is something that is
really important to me personally I
think one of the things that I'm sure
Brian can tell you about as well the
more that we explore other planetary
bodies and our solar system the more we
learn about our own earth and how it
forms and in turn that can lead to how
we might be able to better protect it
some of the things that we can actually
directly see from our own eye is here on
the space station are very relevant to
the changing climate I actually took
some pictures for our crew earth
observations project up here monitoring
some of the glaciers and these were in
particular the glaciers in Patagonia so
in Chile and Argentina and we've been
observing these and taking pictures of
those from the space station for many
years now and monitoring that retreat of
the glaciers that is occurring worldwide
is just very visible with the naked eye
and it's a really a it's a dramatic
example of the changing climate and
really proves and shows me and hopefully
shows the world that we do need to care
we do need to do something to make sure
that we are protecting and taking care
of our one planet Earth ok next we go
back to our middle school scholars and
we have a question from Athena Molina
from Fulton hi my name is Athena Molina
and my question is was it difficult
getting accustomed to space and shines a
new normal things that is a great
question and it is something that we
don't
really think about until we get up here
because we've had so much training on
all the very specialized tasks that we
do how to use the hardware that's up
here how to use the spacesuit how to fix
the toilet just stuff like that that I
mentioned but the one thing that you
can't train for are those really simple
life things what do you do when you
can't just put something down you have
to learn how to use all of the space
around you we have velcro or pieces of
tape all around so that you can put down
put a piece of put an object down and
still know where it's going to be when
you eat you have to realize that if you
have a bag of nuts or candy turning it
upside down is not gonna actually do
anything and help you get that out and
these are all very very simple things
which of course you know in your brain
that it will operate that way but
because our entire as a species through
the entire evolution of the human
species we've always had this effect of
gravity and for our very short lifespans
as individuals we've always had
everything we've known has this effect
of gravity wear down is towards my feet
and if I let go of something it will
fall and really reinterpreting having
your brain relearn all of those things
up here just how how to eliminate that
factor really takes some time and it
does it is very interesting I think it
really shows how plastic the plasticity
of the human brain and how it can adapt
and change just the way that I navigated
around and how my brain adapted to the
new surroundings within a few weeks it
was seemed to be using a totally
different neural pathway in terms of
spatial awareness where instead of just
having down be where my feet is
sometimes during the course of the day I
might need to go and get something up
here so suddenly I'm up here on what
what would look like the ceiling and my
brain and the beginning would sort of do
this flip and suddenly I would think
this was was what I would think was down
again but really it was up from relative
where I was before but even after just a
couple weeks of being up here my brain
had seemed to use a different way of
interpreting that in order to spatially
orient myself and is really interesting
to see as a physiologist I would have
loved to have some kind of EEG or MRI
measurement of the human brain as
sting to life up here in the first few
weeks especially hi my name is Ashley
Nava and my question is can you
communicate with your family yes we can
actually and so it's similar to the way
that I'm talking to you right now you
know we can talk to our ground teams in
Houston using these communications
pathways but I can also just call my
family on a cell phone we use an IP
Phone so it's similar to how Skype would
work and it's a program on our laptops
where we can dial a phone and then we
also have weekly conferences with our
family members so we have a video chat
just like Skype or FaceTime once a week
with our family to help keep us in touch
with everybody that's back on the ground
hi my name is Gianna from Colton k-8 and
my question is before you got accepted
as an astronaut did you ever consider
any other career well I certainly did I
had a whole nother career and that is
thanks to Scripps Institution of
Oceanography and UC San Diego and all of
the mentors and colleagues that I had
during my time as a graduate student
there my time at Scripps was invaluable
they really it really taught me how to
think as a critical thinker how to form
and conduct something efficiently using
the scientific method and most
importantly relevant to my job today it
taught me a lot about working with the
team and I was working as a comparative
physiologist so I was studying animals
in particular animals that live in
extreme environments and trying to
understand how those animals can do the
incredible things they can I was
particularly intrigued by by animals
that live at extraordinary that live and
work at extraordinary depths so diving
animals like emperor penguins and
elephant seals and also high-altitude
animals so birds that migrate over the
tallest mountains on the planet and to
me it was just fascinating to understand
how these animals could live in these
very oxygen deprived to zones so diving
animals penguins seals they are air
breathing breath hold divers just like
you and me but they can drive for 30
minutes for an emperor penguin or two
hours for an elephant seal and it was
just very fascinating to me to try to
think how can they do it what it is is
it that's special and unique and how
have they adapted to enable that
extraordinary behavior so I was working
as a scientist in various universities
and academia conducting research with
animals in the wild and it was a very
fulfilling career but when the
opportunity came to have this childhood
dream job I couldn't pass this up there
are some parallels on earth and one of
those is an airplane effective
affectionately known as the vomit comet
and it is an airplane that flies in a
parabola shaped pattern and essentially
the pilot shuts off the engine at the
top of that parabola so that the plane
and everything isn't in it is in free
fall back to the earth which is
essentially exactly what we are doing up
here on the space station in orbit so
that in the airplane since you're not
quite up high enough away from the earth
and the effects of gravity you only
generate about thirty five seconds of
weightlessness but it does feel a lot
like it does appear just that it only
lasts for those 30-second periods
another thing that seems quite familiar
that is something that you can even do
there in San Diego is go out into the
ocean or go into a swimming pool and if
you go underwater and make yourself
neutrally buoyant so imagine if you have
some weight on you and you're Midway
suspended in the swimming pool so that
you're not moving up and not moving down
that feels a little bit like it but of
course you still have gravity when
you're underwater but that's what we do
to train for spacewalks we have a big
pool where we use the spacesuit in
exactly that way because it does have a
lot of similarities well unfortunately
Jessica our time is rapidly coming to a
close but we want to thank you so much
deepest gratitude to you for spending so
much of your valuable time with us here
in San Diego here at Scripps Institution
of Oceanography at UC San Diego it's
been a real joy and a treat and we can't
wait to go diving and surfing when you
come back here to La Jolla thank you so
much Jessica
thank you everybody is so wonderful to
be able to spend just a little bit of
time with you I only wish we had more
time but please follow along with my
adventure and everything that I'm
posting that's coming down from the NASA
social media and other accounts there
are lots of resources online thank you
and have a wonderful day
[Applause]
well that was amazing
before we break for the for the day I
want to extend a big thank you to the
chaperones to the parents to the
teachers we hope you come back many many
times to UC San Diego and maybe just
maybe if we're lucky we'll get you to
come here to be students here either as
undergraduates or as one of our many
wonderful graduate students so when you
exit there are some exhibits that you
can look at put on by some of the
students here at Scripps Institution of
Oceanography can look through
microscopes you can examine and learn
more about places that you heard about
today Antarctica and the oceans and all
sorts of other things here and it's been
it's been a great pleasure thank you to
the scripps staff for hosting us dr.
Margaret linen for being such a gracious
host and I hope you all enjoy the rest
of your time and please please come back
again visit us at Scripps and the Birch
Aquarium thank you so much have a great
day
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you